this person said I was wondering if we
could get a Julie update as far as I
know she's doing well I have not been to
Lexington to visit her yet Lindsey
Chrisley is speaking out about stepmom
Julie and I just want to talk about it
this week so that it can go away I have
raised thanking children for that I'm
blessed reality star has visited her dad
Todd Chrisley at his Florida prison
where he's serving a 12-year sentence
for bank fraud and tax evasion he looks
very very good
um I told him I said even your hair
looks better a little bit longer and a
little bit grayer meanwhile Julie's 655
miles away from him in Kentucky serving
seven years behind bars this person said
I was wondering if we could get a Julie
update as far as I know she's doing well
um Savannah said that she's doing very
well my mom she's
honestly
she's doing really well what we will not
do is we will not break as Lindsay
explains on her Southern tea podcast
she's yet to see her stepmom in person
three months after Julian Todd
surrendered to prison
I have not been to Lexington to visit
her yet there was a different process
that
I had to go through
um and the process at her facility looks
very different than the process of my
dad's facility and so I sent in all of
my paperwork and am yet to hear back
regarding the visiting I don't want
anybody reading into something that is
just simply not there I love my children
more than I've ever loved anything in
life we're going to always be there for
each other another topic on Lindsay's
mind a recent ET sit down Abby Lee
Miller do you know who she is apparently
they're in real trouble that's a long
time the dance mom star who also spent
time in prison on tax evasion charges
told E.T earlier this month the advice
she allegedly shared with Todd before
his conviction I had been dming Todd
because he was always talking about the
court in Georgia and they said this and
they said that and I said be careful you
know if they want you they're going to
get you what she did in my opinion was
very inappropriate she aired what she
claimed was Private Communications with
my dad and I don't believe that she
would have been Brazen enough to do it
had my dad not been currently
incarcerated he's very busy he is not
going to be able to handle like the soap
and the towels and I can confidently
assure you that there is no concern
about towels or soap I would like to
encourage her to spend her time giving
back to the community and stops spewing
the nonsense
also this week Lindsay's sister Savannah
on her unlocked podcast and currently
you're not doing a show on TV right
um not at this moment drop in New
details about the family's hopes to
return to reality TV but there is a show
that will come back okay and I think
that is where boundaries have to be set
it would be how we are all dealing with
things how we're navigating it together
as a family Savannah's comments came
after Dad Todd previously teased the
documentary that's being that we're
working on right now is going to be very
telling and we hope that our fans will
Embrace that what do you know about this
documentary and the message that the
Chrisley family wants to now show the
world I don't have any details about the
documentary uh I can just tell you there
is there is a story there about what
they've been through the past year or
two that hasn't been told I think they'd
want folks to know that they are the
same people they've always been that
they didn't do these things and they're
going to fight to get their name cleared
foreign